It is late and I'm sleepy but I
feel strangely motivated to
do SAT problems, so I will do
SAT problems. So we'll start a
new test.
This is going to be test 2, and
we're going to start on
section 3, and that's
on page 459 of the--
what's that book called?
The Official SAT Study Guide
by The College Board.
So let's get started.
So the first problem,
problem number 1.
It said, if 3b plus 1 is less
than 10, which of the
following cannot to
be the value of b?
So which of the following cannot
And they give a couple of
choices: a, minus 1; b, 0; c,
1; d, 2; e, 3.
And you could start with choice
a and just keep going
through all of them and inspect
it really fast. The
way I would do it is I would
automatically convert this
equation, subtract one
from both sides.
You say, well, this is the same
thing as 3 times b has to
be less than 9.
I just subtracted 1 from both
sides of this, right?
And if you look at these, well
3 times negative 1, that's
negative 3, that's
less than 9.
3 times 0, that's 0,
that's less than 9.
Let me write that.
3 times negative 1
is negative 3.
3 times 0 is 0.
3 times 1 is 3, 3
times 2 is 6.
These are all less
than 9, right?
I just substituted each
of these for b.
But 3 times 3, that is actually
equal to 9, right?
3 times 3 is equal to 9, which
is not less than 9.
So our choice is e.
Number 2, I think I've space
to do it on this without
having to clear the
chalkboard.
It says, 2 to the 4x
is equal to 16.
Whenever you see one of these
problems where the variable is
in the exponent and you have
different bases here, the
trick is really just to convert
them to the same base.
So can I write 16
as a power of 2?
Well sure.
Two to the what power is 16?
Well, 2 to the squared is 4, 2
to the 3rd power is 8, to the
4th power is 16, right?
So we could write this same
equation as 2 to the 4x is
equal to, another way of writing
16 is 2 to the 4th
power, right?
And now, that this should
seem a little bit more
straightforward.
2 to the 4x is the same thing
as 2 to the 4th, so 4x must
equal 4, right?
4x must equal 4, so
x is equal to 1.
And that choice exists, so I
feel confident in my answer.
Let's move on.
I think soon.
I might be coming down
with the flu.
Let's hope not, because that
would limit my ability to turn
out SAT problems on YouTube.
Number 3.
How much greater is r minus
2 than r plus 5?
Well, if I wanted to know how
much one number is greater
than another, if I ask you how
much greater is 10 than 5,
what do I do?
Well, I take 10 minus 5
and that's my answer.
So example: 10 minus
5 is 5, so 10 is 5
greater than 5, right?
So if I want to know how much
greater than r minus 2 is r
plus 5, right-- and r plus 5
is going to be the greater
one-- you just subtract them.
So we say r plus 5
minus r minus 2.
So r plus 5 minus r-- I'm just
distributing the negative
number-- plus 2.
The r's cancel out, and
you get the answer.
It's 7.
And you really didn't even
have to do it this way,
because this r could be any
number, and the answer should
be the same no matter
what r is.
And obviously it worked out
because the r's canceled out.
The easiest thing, let me just
assume that r is 0 because we
can, because it shouldn't
matter what r is.
If r was 0, then the question
is how much greater than
negative 2 is plus 5, right?
I just assumed that r was 0.
And then you would do
the same thing.
You would do 5 minus negative
2, which is equal to 7.
And you could draw them on the
number line if you wanted to
visually approach
this problem.
All right, this next problem
looks visual.
Problem number 4.
OK, so it has a square.
I don't need to draw it fancy,
let me just draw it freehand.
So, it's a box, it
looks like this.
They say that the box
is open at the top.
So that's the bottom
right there.
OK, and they give
measurements.
This end is 4, this end is 3,
and then the height is 2.
And they were to say if we were
to essentially cut the
sides of this box and flatten
it all out, which of these
choices are that this
box-- this is a pure
visualization problem.
But to flatten it out,
as I said, you would
cut you this line.
You'd cut this line.
I'm just imagining
what I would do
if I had some scissors.
And there's no top to
the box, right?
And then I would take this side
and I would flatten it
out that way.
This side, I would flatten
it out that way.
That back side, I would flatten
it out there, and that
side, I would flatten
it out there.
So you'd have the base.
The base would look like this
where you have 3 would be the
width, right?
This side corresponds
to this side, right?
This side would correspond
to this side.
And that would be of length 4.
And then this height 2--
let me draw that.
So this flap, which I
draw in brown, would
come out like this.
And this distance right
here would be 2.
And then you would have
another-- let's say, the flap
in the back.
Let me draw it in another
color, in a dark purple.
This flap in the back would
come out like this, flat.
It would also have 2 length.
And then the other 2 flaps,
like this one, would
come out like this.
And of course this has 2 here.
And then finally I have
that flap in the back.
I need to pick a color.
This flap in the back would
come out like that, right?
And I'll shade it in
like I shaded in
the original picture.
And that would also have 2.
So this is a pure visualization
problem, there's
not a lot more that I can
do to explain this.
And there's no top
to this box.
And we had a bottom.
So this is the choice.
See, if we rotated it around a
little bit, it's choice e.
Actually rotated it around,
because choice
e looks like this.
Choice e looks like this.
I'm not drawing it that
well, but it looks
something like this.
Where they say that this length
is 4, this length is 2,
and this length is 3.
So they took this and they
essentially rotated it so that
this side becomes this side.
And then this side becomes
that side.
So they just rotated
it clockwise a
little over 90 degrees.
And that's how they
got that answer.
So this is a pure visualization
problem.
With that, I have about 90
seconds left in this video, so
I'll wait to do it in
the next video.
I'll see